2015 is the European year for
development much has already been
achieved the number of people living in
extreme poverty has been reduced by more
than a half since nineteen ninety nine
out of ten children in developing
countries now start school with
unprecedented equality for girls and
boys attendance the European Union and
its member states significantly
contributed to these achievements but
our work joining forces with our partner
countries is not done yet child and
maternal mortality rates are still
unacceptably high climate change
migration radicalism and virus outbreaks
and challenge our future now is the time
to act together each one of us can play
a role for a more peaceful and
sustainable world our world our dignity
our future get involved
you